decir que la operación llevada a cabo
por estos hombres esa mañana no es su
rutina habitual sería quedarse corto
todos ellos son reservistas o han
servido en las dos unidades más
prestigiosas de las fuerzas especiales
israelíes
ocupan los lugares del foro Kong un
grupo de reflexión de derecha que apoya
la reforma de la justicia y hace campaña
a su favor reservistas de la unidad de
élite evacuados por la policía una
escena surrealista en esta sociedad
israelí tan ligada a su ejército Aunque
hoy muchos dudan de él Bill dice que
lleva mucho tiempo haciéndose esta
pregunta pero ahora tiene una respuesta
Clara hago muchos días de voluntariado
pero no servirá un país donde alguien
lleva la democracia La dictadura
quedar en casa iré a la calle hasta que
no vuelva a la democracia no haré mi
reserva para estos hombres de todas las
generaciones el gobierno está atacando
directamente los fundamentos
democráticos del país este francotirador
de 22 años dice que algunos de sus
compañeros ya están boicoteando el
servicio
la semana pasada en la formación estaba
solo la mitad del personal
la otra mitad no se presentó y creo que
cuando se apruebe la ley la mayoría ya
no se presentará
simplemente sustituirán a los pilotos me
sustituirán como francotirador y ya está
este conjunto de leyes le quita la
esencia a este país ser judío y
democrático lo cual no es evidente por
sí solo
pero en los últimos 75 años habíamos
encontrado un equilibrio y ahora se está
deteriorando
[Música]
cada semana empeora tengo mucho miedo de
lo que va a pasar aquí estamos al borde
de una guerra civil
[Música]
las palabras son fuertes Más allá de la
Reforma de la Justicia subrayan La
fractura entre este Israel laico y el
que apoya a los supremacistas religiosos
que llevan el peso del gobierno para el
poder ejecutivo estos reservistas que se
manifiestan son anarquistas sin embargo
Esta no es la primera palabra que viene
a la mente cuando uno conoce al general
relic shafire antiguo piloto de casa
formó parte del escuadrón que fue a
bombardear el reactor nuclear de osirak
al sureste de Bagdad en 1981 coordina un
grupo de más de 1000 antiguos pilotos el
ejército incluidos reservistas activos
comprometidos con la lucha contra la
reforma
no se trata de una reforma judicial
también es una Revolución judicial
así como una Revolución teocrática
los pilotos de f-15 f-16 o cualquier
avión
la gente que vuela está diciendo no
volaremos aviones en este entorno
dictatorial
y esto presiona los responsables
Esperamos que les hagan entender
que no solo tienen que parar sino
también que construyen una reforma que
sea aceptable no solo para la extrema
derecha sino también para la gente del
centro
los pilotos de reserva tienen un peso
considerable dentro del ejército porque
sus unidades dependen de ellos realicen
regularmente ataques en Siria o gaza al
día siguiente el general se afirmabilizó
a sus tropas son antiguos pilotos o
veteranos del programa espaciales
israelí se preparan para llevar a cabo
una operación caracol en el aeropuerto
de tel aviv y este es uno de los
primeros pilotos de la fuerza aérea un
piloto de f-16
es el comandante de Misión y de las
otras misiones que hacemos mientras se
acercan a la terminal principal estos
dos combatientes plantean un argumento
muy extendido entre reservistas y
militares activos para ellos Una
institución judicial debilitada puede
exponerlos a un proceso internacional
que el tribunal Penal Internacional de
la haya solo puede procesar a los
soldados y su sistema judicial nacional
no es capaz de hacerlo
System is no
Así que si ya no tenemos un tribunal
supremo se abre la puerta de las
acusaciones del tribunal Penal
Internacional
como tenemos un sistema judicial fuerte
y reconocido
siempre hemos estado protegidos
gracias a eso precisamente pero si
eliminamos eso nadie va a proteger a los
soldados
por ahora el gobierno israelí no parece
escuchar los temores de los reservistas
a los que se niegan a servir el
Ministerio de comunicación les dice
váyanse al infierno Israel no los
necesita